From a society that refuses to stop making movies out of fanfic
potlucks comes to Phil is based on a 15 year old Wattpad that
became smash it's thanks to a demographic I've aged away out of, Hey.
Hey, close on young lady at my day. Movie teens act that age appropriately.
Oh yeah. That's better. Kissing booths.
Get ready for an old school romcom with all the hallmarks of a John used classic
sexual harassment, double standards for women.
And there you are treating her some slot.
You picked up at the club and Molly Ringwald as you journey to Los Angeles.
So white you'll swear. You're actually in South Africa because you are,
that goes and gets into a fight on the first day of school. Great story.
Now about those blood diamonds,
meet L a high school girl, struggling to escape her inner monologue.
In spite of what happened tonight.
I couldn't stop thinking about what Noah said to me.
Voiceover butts in every five minutes, like a Netflix version.
Look, Libby. You obviously couldn't see this, but my heart just did a back flip.
Yeah. That's what the Epping is.
Never great to hear your childhood crush say it's super gross in your pants.
I'd want it to listen to this crap. I'd buy the audio book. Okay.
Life throws curves.
Shut up. Ah, this is all your fault. Kissing booth. Oh.
Set your lips to smooch.
When El is caught between the Flynn brothers to do two's parents work in the
money factory there's Lee who builds a friendship with them based on
21 simple rules.
Only your best friend gets to know your birthday wishes. Well, number seven,
no matter how mad you are at your best friend, you have to forgive them.
If they give you ice cream rule number 18, always be happy for your well.
Number six, if you can't tell your best friend about something you're doing,
you probably shouldn't be doing number 19.
Always go to the same school as your member. Number two,
never share our secrets with anyone else. Number 16,
when your best he needs you there, you need to be on number five,
always do the Thanksgiving wishbone with your bestie.
But rule nine says relatives are off limits. So no kissing his older brother,
Noah. Well, he has to keep his hands off. Her dad and little brother,
but rules were made to be broken and sparks will fly.
When Elle gets trapped in her very first abusive relationship, Izzy,
violent check,
controlling, duh,
the car blames the victim natch wearing a skirt like that is asking
for it. Still he's freakishly tall. And she got boobs over the summer.
So climb that red flag girl,
just get a burner phone and memorize the exits to a sixth gazebo. So creepy yet.
So hot
hormones will rage thanks to their high school blindfolded kissing booth,
which isn't just a gross idea that you'd get the entire school administration
can.
It's.
Also the biggest cliche in teen fiction. Since the popular girl click,
who just wants to start drama. Oh, they do that one too.
How about to get too wasted and table dancing?
Wow. A big prom night finale.
Uh, team Jacob Love triangle in the sequel.
You have no business talking to me really well.
Why don't you just throw in a dramatic,
rather the airport sequence for good measure. It's cliches all the way down.
People. This film exists for one reason. And one reason only.
[Inaudible] wait. Who's filming him.
So settle it for some good old fashioned Zoomer escapism,
where everyone is pretty finds love,
gets into Harvard and pays their way with dance, dance, revolution, tournament,
winnings. But at the end of the day, they're still relatable.
Cause sometimes they fall down, go boo.
[Inaudible].
In what may be two garbage films with horrible messages.
But if they made movies out of the cringy stuff you wrote at 15, well,
I'm still taking offers for Ninja Viking versus boop Lee's Netflix.
Give me a call.
That's a lifetime girl. Never got to happen. Story.
Simple. Ain't easy. I did not hit her as book. I did not. Uh,
highly paycheck, NP, melted plastics,
30 and flirty.
So many George teenagers.
Marco always has the last word.
Rachel never leaves happy.
Rachel, Rachel and I never went into.
This old man on patrol, checking the sex gazebo,
Not another teen movie until you've learned your lesson.
Does everyone in this movie delete their text history, shady.